welcome to the zombie apocalypse tour
Las Vegas the first of many zombie
apocalypse tours featuring the halt
thing zombie and all things survival
in case of zombie attack this is the
place for you to be however I will not
be here but let me show you some of the
things that we do have just in this
little container here there's 200
servings of actually very good
restaurant quality food we have our
freeze-dried section this food here is
very good any kind of water will
reconstitute these but you want to err
towards the warm water just for
palatability this section here is kind
of cool this starts out this is our bug
out bag section bugging out is just a
term used for if you've got to grab your
stuff and get out of town get out of
town quick this is a self hydrating
water pouch if you can throw in a puddle
of water you can throw that in the sewer
you can throw that in the toilet
it'll self hydrate and on this side you
actually end up with a drink that has
electrolytes in it this is a 3600
calories of I can't say good stuff it
doesn't taste too bad it tastes about
like pie crust but it's 3600 calories
that'll get you surviving for quite a
while this is everything you need to
survive the zombie apocalypse this over
here is everything you need to have fun
while surviving the zombie apocalypse
actually stun guns work on zombies for
about 48 hours after infection other
body tissues are still connected
afterwards it's just good against humans
who are trying to take the food that you
were smart enough to put away this is
the one weapon that actually bears the
name zombie this is our zombie machete
this thing is a very functional survival
weapon it's got some good weight to it a
little sewing kit matches so yourself
back up after you've been bitten by the
zombies right but if you remove if your
amount of healthy tissue around the
injured area and you do that quickly
enough you can't not you can survive
before you're infected
this is our zombie practice killing area
bleeding targets these are kind of cool
shoot these these will take up to 2,000
shots this is something that we've just
come out with this is a bleeding paper
target and then of course the most fun
is our Samba targets these are exploding
targets the actual components called a
man doll but you hit these with a
high-explosive round and hook out you
want to be a hundred yards away from
this these things are very violent and
fun and legal in all 50 states
earthquakes tornadoes the government
takeover or zombies all the techniques
are similar you need the same things if
you prepare for a zombie attack you're
prepared for anything is gonna in
tonight would you man win here with me
now the next question is is it a real
gun
where's they're they're the only kind
that are any good it's okay that's okay
we're talking about the apocalypse there
okay field stoves